dire qu'il y à 16 mois les travaux du
rêve n'était même pas encore commencé
sur la rive-sud à vitesse grand v
aujourd'hui il avance voici une partie
des 18 km de structures aériennes
prévues au projet ce tronçon reliera la
future gare du quartier situé à la
hauteur du dix30 au terminus rive-sud de
brossard c'est là à l'intersection des
autoroutes 10 et 30 qu'on retrouvera un
stationnement de 3000 places un centre
d'entretien pour les wagons et puis ce
futur centre névralgique
alors les poutres grise que vous avez
juste ici les dix fait ce qu'on est en
train de construire
c'est le futur centre de contrôle du
réseau express métropolitains le cerveau
en fait duré comme c'est un système un
système sans conducteur tous les trains
qui soit 60 km d'ici à deux montagnes
sainte anne de bellevue tous leurs
mouvements sont sont décidés et opérer à
partir d'ici c'est aussi ici à brossard
contestera les nouveaux trains à compter
de l'automne 2020 des wagons du rem
rouleront le long de l'autoroute 10 sur
une distance de trois kilomètres et demi
pendant 13 mois
l'idée c'est de faire circuler les
trains de tester le fonctionnement des
trains en hiver et en été de tester le
fonctionnement des portes
le constructeur confirme qu'il aura
accès à la travée centrale du nouveau
penchant plaît dans les prochaines
semaines pour ces travaux leur m y
passera avant de se rendre dans
griffintown puis au centre ville tous en
ligne donc pour inaugurer comme prévu la
branche sud du projet fin 2021
l'ouverture du tronçon central qui
passera dans le tunnel du mont royal est
quant à elle toujours envisagé fin 2022
mais mettre aux normes cette structure
centenaire sera un défi colossal et on
sent la prudence encore beaucoup de
discussions sur la sueur sur la
conformité il ya des choix on travaille
ensemble pour le faire avancer
aujourd'hui là alors qu'on se parle avec
ce qu'ils regardent et là on viserait à
rentrer dans nos échéances et mais ça
n'a alors pas moins ne faut pas
minimiser l'ampleur du défi les branches
vers de montagne et sainte anne de
bellevue pucelle vers l'aéroport
montréal-trudeau seront quant à elles
inaugurée fin 2023
ou plutôt ici jean-sébastien cloutier
radio canada brossât